Das ist ein sehr guter Film, das ist ein sehr guter Film. Schön, dass ihr da seid zu dieser erfrischenden Sommerausgabe mit diesem ganz fantastischen Intro von Chris.
Vielen Dank an Chris für dieses fantastische Intro, dass das richtige Sommer französische Riviera-Stimmung hier reinbringt in unsere triste graue Aufnahmestube. Hat jedes Land eine Riviera eigentlich? Ich glaube, jeder kriegt eine Riviera. Ist Riviera nicht eine Promenade? Ich glaube, du brauchst sogar eine Riviera, um ein offizielles Land zu werden. Es gibt ja so diese Landesbehörde, um ein Land zu sein, brauchst du ein Gebiet, eine Währung und eine Hymne. Und eine Riviera. Richtig, 1962 hat man gesagt, wir haben hier 100 Millionen Länder, das ist Bullshit, die Hymnen sind kreuz und quer, Scar ist da bei Metal, da haben sie gesagt, nee, wir brauchen noch eine Riviera. Und seitdem muss jedes Land eine Riviera haben. Ja, tatsächlich, deswegen wurde 1994 auch in Tschechien eine extra Riviera erstmal angelegt, damit die rückwirkend... Aber die Tschechinen sagen ja nicht mehr Riviera, die Tschechinen sagen ja heute Rivesco, Rivetti, Rivelli. Naja, ich weiß nicht genau, also Portugal hat glaube ich eine Riviera, Brasilien hat mehrere Rivieren, wie gesagt, ich glaube es ist einfach ein ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich sage ja immer, Riviera ist da, wo du bist. Riviera ist für mich meine Riviera. Das freut mich, danke. Da geht der oberen Hemdknopf auf, da hat man irgendwie so eine schöne Brise unterm Arm. Der Unterige zu. Ich habe ein Riesenproblem mit Schweissflecken. Ja, ich auch. Unterm Arm. Unterm Arm gar nicht. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Auf der Brust habe ich das. Nee, stopp, stopp, stopp. Areret, du redest jetzt von Schweissflecken im Sinne von man sieht den Schweiss. Ich rede von dem widerlichen, verkrusteten Scheiss, den man nicht mehr rauskriegt. Verkrusteter, hartnäckiger Schweiss. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch keinen verkrusteten Schweiss gesehen. Doch, doch, doch, wird so richtig steif und richtig hart. Es ist so richtig krustig. Sieht das aus wie so Salzkristalle hier? Es wird aus irgendeinem Grund gelblich. Ich habe das Gefühl, alles, was widerlich ist, wird irgendwie so gelb irgendwann. Ich glaube, alles, was aus dem Körper kommt, wird irgendwann gelblich. Alles trendet so gelb. Ich bin mir sicher, dass wenn du irgendwie ein Glas spuckst und es lang genug stehen lässt, es wird gelb irgendwann. Alles wird irgendwann gelb, wenn es ekelhaft wird. Das ist so Go-To-Farbe für Ekel. Gelb. Ist Käse nicht auch einfach nur die ekelige Form von Milch? Gut, dass du es mal ansprichst, endlich sagt es mal jemand. Ekelmilch. Ja, das finde ich eine gute Trendmarke. Wäre das ein Startup? Ich finde es auch gut, dass es Startups gibt, die gegen Produkte sind, immer so, unser Produkt ist das beste, kauft unser Produkt. Wir brauchen mehr Geschäfte, die sagen, kauft weniger Toast und die Leute so, wer finanziert eure Werbung? Sagen wir nicht, sagen wir nicht und dann ist es auch wie zu Kitzeln, wir sagen es nicht. Kamps, wir sagen es nicht. Das Logo von dir sieht ja auch so aus, wie der Kamps Brezel, nur so leicht verändert. Wie kreativ ist das Kamps-Logo denn eigentlich, oder? Eine Brezel?
Brezel. Was ist denn sonst?
Super gut.
Wie kreativ.
Mega kreativ.
Ist aber eine Brezel.
Ja, aber die verkaufen Brezeln, also ist das Logo eine Brezel.
Was ich kreativ finde, ist das FedEx-Logo, da ist ein Pfeil drin.
Gut, ja, okay.
Da ist ein Pfeil drin und ich werde die Hälfte der Zuschauer sagt jetzt, wenn ihr es googelt,
ho, dieses Geräusch. Stefan ist wieder in seiner, ich habe geradegrad-ein-Buzzfeed-Artikel-Gesicht gelesen. Dieses Geräusch werden die hören. Boah, das ist aber gar nicht so fest. Hand vor dem Kopf, oh! Nee, nee, Hand vor dem Kopf ist aber grössflächiger, das ist so. Das ist Hand vor dem Kopf. Aber das ist aber eher Facepalm. Ne, Facepalm ist nicht nur Stirn, sondern das ganze Gesicht. Facepalm ist, du bedeckst dein Gesicht und Scham. Aber ich habe mein Leben lang das Fertigste-Logo angeguckt, aber es ist ein Pfeil drin, ist doch das Geräusch. Stefan haut sich jetzt mit der Handballen auf die Stirn. So ein dumpfes... Schreib das mal in Drehbuch. Wie schreibst du das in Drehbuch? Führt Handballen in Erkenntnis, in einem Anflug von Erkenntnis führt Handballen und dann kommen wieder Notes, Skriptes zu lang und das sind die ersten Sätze, die rausfliegen. Am Ende des Tages waren unsere Skripte, also man versuchte ja am Anfang, Sorkinesk, schöne Skripte zu schreiben, bei dem ist ja scheißegal, wie lange die Seitenzahlen sind, bei uns achtet man auf Seitenzahlen und deswegen habe ich auch irgendwann angefangen, das sind die ersten Sachen, diese schönen formul Action-Texte, das sind die ersten Sachen, die rausfliegen. Was ist so? Äh, Okay-Zeichen. Zeigt an, tipptopp. Zeigt an, kursiv, tipptopp, alles gut. Taucher, taucher gut. Das habe ich gerade schreiben müssen. Die typische Kopf-ab-Hand-Schüttel-Geste. Ja, aber es ist nicht diese, es ist nicht die Kehle durchschneiden Geste, sondern dieses, hör auf jetzt.
Habe ich lustig, was er genau gerade geschrieben. Wirklich? Und was hast du geschrieben? Ich habe geschrieben, Moritz wirft ihm wilde Gesten zu und dann inklusiv die Gedanken, lass es, auf gar keinen Fall, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist oft eigentlich das Beste, signalisiert, lass es. Ja, signalisiert, wirft ihm wilde Gesten zu, auf gar keinen Fall, machen wir das.
Wirft ihm wilde Gesten, du bist ein Poet geworden in den letzten Jahren, du bist wirklich über dich hinausgewachsen. Du machst dich über einen lustig. Überhaupt nicht. Gestikuliert, lass, lass mich, lass es, würde ich schreiben. Gestikuliert, lass mich in Ruhe. Lass es sein. Aber läuft gut, Staffel zwei wurde bestätigt, grosser Aufruhr im Internet, Staffel zwei soll es geben, wie läuft's? Wir sind mittendrin. Zeitreise. Das will ich nicht sagen, Zeitrast, wie immer. Ja, ich mein Zeitreiseplot, jetzt wird's verrückt, jetzt kommt Zeitreiseplot. Jetzt kommen die Zombies, das ist ja klar. Typisch Staffel zwei Kram. Ich wollte gerade den Tweet absetzen, Staffel zwei ist eigentlich Fanfiction schreiben. Staffel eins ist eine Staffel eins schreiben, Staffel zwei ist Fanfiction. Jetzt ist es einfach nur, was will man denn noch sehen? Jetzt ist es einfach nur Bucketlist arbeiten, worauf haben wir denn noch Bock? Die Staffel existiert ja, die Geschichte existiert ja. Jetzt ist es ja nur, was wollen wir, worauf haben wir jetzt Bock bei den Charakteren? Du hast ja keine Entwicklungsarbeit mehr zu leisten. Und wie sehr lässt du dich jetzt von den Kommentaren der Zuschauer beeinflussen? Gar nicht. Also wenn jetzt jemand schreibt, wie geil wäre es, wenn jetzt Moritz Mutter noch zurückkommt und irgendwie eine noch krassere Drogendealerin wäre und was ist das für eine Geste?
Stefan signalisiert, lass es.
Nee, du bist komplett abgespachtelt von allem anderen.
Nee, ich möchte das erzählen, was ich cool finde, die anderen Autoren, mit denen ich das schreibe, wollen erzählen, was sie gut finden, da achtet man jetzt nicht auf Publikum. Aber man hat schon ein bisschen den Drang, die eigene Serie kaputt zu schreiben, oder? Ich will frei haben, ich will wieder Urlaub haben. Ehrlich gesagt, so nach so einem Flop und so ein schönes, ja das war jetzt eine schöne Erfahrung, aber jetzt reicht es auch, hätte mir jetzt auch gut getan, ehrlich gesagt. Du brauchst mal wieder einen Flop, glaube ich. Ja, schon schönen Flop. So ein schönes, gute Arbeit. Ja, du brauchst mal wieder was. Apropos Flop, wollen wir gleich zum Fail der Woche kommen? Wir kommen gleich zum Fail der Woche kommen, ja. Dann bitte. Ich weiss nicht genau, was der Fail der Woche ist, ich überlastiere die Anvaluation. Wir kommen zum Fail der Woche, und zwar, wie vielleicht schon der eine oder andere mitbekommen hat, ist mal wieder Thema geworden die Podcast-Ufo-Telegram-Gruppe.
Habe ich nicht so mitbekommen, ich bin ganz gespannt.
Aber erinnere mich gleich an den zweiten Fail der Woche, der mir gerade bei der Nahrmoderation eingefallen hat.
Ja, Telegram-Gruppe war bis jetzt relativ unauffällig, hier und da mal in Erscheinung getreten, könnt ihr gerne joinen, Telegram-Podcast-Ufo, sowas an der Ecke. Und ja, anscheinend hat... Theorie 1. Eine Nazi-Gruppe hat die Podcast-Ufo, die beeinflussbare Podcast-Ufo-Community infiltriert. Ja, weiter, weiter. Theorie zwei, es gibt mit der Riviera hat die Podcast-Ufo-Community jetzt alle Kriterien für ein eigenes Land zusammen. Ja. Und im Kontinent Ozeanien gibt es jetzt das Podcast-Ufo, das ist das Podcast-Ufo-Land. Ich sag mal, es liegt irgendwo dazwischen. Ja, es liegt meistens dazwischen.
Denn ein Mitglied der Podcast-Ufo-Telegram-Gruppe hat es für notwendig gehalten, pornografische Inhalte zu posten. Wow! Aha! Da wird ja drüber gelacht. Hahaha, Sex, Penis, die hat kein Kleid an. Hahaha, ich habe einen grossen slash kleinen Penis, lacht euch kaputt. Haha, schaut den mal an, der hat fast nichts an. So, Gags schreiben sich von selbst. Ist lustig. Und da haben die nichts besseres zu tun, als widerlichen Schund zu posten. Ekelhaft. Herabsetzung der wunderschönen Sexualität des Menschen. Ekelhaft. Jetzt frage ich natürlich, sind Bilder nicht per se verboten? Ich wiederhole die Frage, weil ich in ein fragendes Gesicht gucke.
Ich wiederhole die Frage, ist in der Podcast-UFO-Gruppe Emojis sind verboten. Bilder sind streng erlaubt. Strengstens erlaubt. Erwünscht. Und ja, natürlich riesen Aufruhr, Telegram hat das sofort mitbekommen, Doktor Telegram ist immer am Hebel, Gruppe gesperrt, kaputt, ja, erstmal Strom abgezogen. Wie klingt das immer so ein Podcast-Hofo? Da sind ja noch viele Leute drin. Wie klingt das, wenn man das abschaltet? Einfach weg. So ein Vakuum. Gut, dann war es aus. War aus, ähm, ich habe dann wieder den Brief bekommen, ja, sehr geehrter Herr Will, die Gruppe, da treiben sich einige Halunken um und ja, ich habe da jetzt mal Kevin zum Admin ernannt, der soll da mal aufräumen. Ja? Kevin ist Admin? Geht da jetzt mit einem eisernen Kamm durch. Wie hast du denn Kevin jetzt ausgewählt als Admin? Ich, es gab verschiedene Auswahlkriterien und ich dachte, die erste Person, die mich anschreibt und sagt, ich will Admin werden, wird Admin. Und es ist Kevin geworden. Vielleicht wird es ein eigener Nationalstaat, man weiß es nicht, Börsengang steht noch aus. Hat Kevin wenigstens Profilbild, was einigermaßen sympathisch wirkt und seriös? Mittel, eher unauffällig, würde ich sagen. Unauffällig heißt das graue Männchen. Ist mir nicht in Erinnerung geblieben. Aber ja, grosse Enttäuschung, einen dicken, dicken Fail der Woche an die Telegram-Gruppe, dass ihr da nicht mal die Hose zulassen könnt. Daumen runter, von uns gibt's einen grossen Daumen runter. Wap, wap. Ja, ein weiterer Fail der Woche. Wir haben letzte Woche nämlich die Face-App besprochen. Oh, grosser Fail, denn kurz nach der Veröffentlichung der Folge kam heraus, der russische Geheimdienst steckt hinter den lustigen alten Gesichtern. Bitte nicht mehr benutzen oder benutzen, aber dann halt auf eigene Gefahr. Das wollte ich nur kurz sagen. Die sammeln die Bilder ja irgendwie, die sammeln die Daten und haben dann ganz viele Bilder und machen dann damit...
Ja, die machen dann damit...
Ja, die machen dann damit, sammeln die, um herauszufinden...
Ich glaube, es ist primär, wenn man jetzt herausfindet, wie Leute aussehen, wenn sie alt sind, und die als Algorithmus festlegen, die Leute, die es posten, gehen ja wahrscheinlich davon aus, dass es ein realistisches Foto ist, deswegen posten sie es, weil sie lustig finden, weil es realistisch ist, dann können sie so zurückberechnen, wie Leute, die alt sind, damals aussahen, um dann vielleicht irgendwelche Straftäter zu finden oder sowas. Ach so, okay, wenn dann mal jemand einbricht und sagt, ah, Sie sehen ja genauso aus wie der Rentner, den wir durch die FaceApp generiert haben, waren Sie das mal früher?
Genau.
Dann sagt der ja und dann haben sie dich. Ne, ich glaube, es geht primär darum, und das finde ich wirklich interessant, dass die sehr viele Daten wollen, weil man meldet sich ja sehr schnell an und stimmt sehr vielen Sachen zu, zum Beispiel, dass die auf alle Fotos zugreifen können, auf die Kamera zugreifen können, auf das Mikrofon zugreifen können etc.
Und du meldest dich dafür mit deinem Facebook-Konto an oder mit deinem Gmail-Konto. Das heißt, die haben direkt sehr viele Informationen über dich und Daten sind natürlich gerade irgendwie das the way to go.
Und das Interessante ist ja, dass sie wahrscheinlich diese Idee zuerst hatten. Wir brauchen eine App, mit der wir viel Daten sammeln können und dann einfach eine mega geile Idee haben. Und das denke ich mir die ganze Zeit. Ich will ja, mein Goal ist einfach nur eine App kreieren, mit der ich sehr, sehr reich werde. Und jetzt, das ist aber genau die gleiche Denkprozesse, den die auch hatten. Die denken einfach vom Erfolg aus, was ich total interessant finde, wie ball sie, und sie hatten danach eine mega coole Idee. Aber du musst jetzt halt nur irgendjemandem diese ganzen Gesichter verkaufen. Einfach sagen, hey, sind jetzt 240 Millionen Gesichter?
Nein.
Komm.
Facebook?
Honi?
Gehen, da sind die überall, oder auf Instagram.
Facebook, oh scheiße, geile Idee, Facebook, ja, ja, FaceApp, geil, geniale Idee. Aber ich glaube, man kann sowas gut sabotieren. Das heisst jetzt Aufruf an alle Widerstandskämpfer da draussen, macht einfach mal einen Smiley auf dem Blatt Papier und macht damit die Face-App, geht, dann haben die so ein altes, so ein vergilbtes Blatt Papier. Ah, ich störe da mit Augenringe. Das war nämlich so Augenringe und Gehstock. Und stört dadurch dann den Algorithmus, dass dann irgendwie ganz viele Fake-Bilder
drin sind. Oder macht irgendwie so von so Superhelden oder aus Comics oder aus Büchern oder hat einen unterm falschen Namen und verwirrt die. Wenn ich jetzt durchs Metz gehen würde in New York, Metropolitan Museum, würde ich glaube hier einfach diesen Dingern, die da rumstehen, so, also da stehen ja manchmal so Indianer rum oder so, oder alte Bilder von alten Königen, die nur 23 wurden oder sowas.
Den habe ich das mal ausprobiert, einfach so.
Wenn ich so einen Tag mit mir im Metz mit der Face-App verbracht, glaube ich, ist schon cool.
Da sind ein paar Verwandten ausprobiert, wo die älter sind, und das sieht schon interessant aus.
Die sind jetzt alle in Russland, die auch abgeschleppt wurden, die ganzen Menschen. Abgeschleppt? Entschuldigung. Ich meine, es ist natürlich... Abgeschleppt. Russland hat die abgeschleppt. Vor allem ist es halt so ein bisschen, du machst halt dieses Bild von dir und denkst dann, scheiße, ich werde irgendwann aussehen wie Otto Walkes. Oder halt irgendwie sowas. Bei dir ist es Harald Schmidt leider.. Bei dir ist Harald Schmidt, aber Harald Schmidt geht noch. Ich finde auch, Harald Schmidt geht. Ist einfach ein guter Typ im Alter, ein sympathischer Opi. Ja, ja, könnte noch kippen, glaube ich. Ich glaube, Harald Schmidt könnte noch kippen. Ist mein Kippkandidat der Woche. Menschlich ist er gekippt, schon lange. Viel ganz furchtbare Aussagen getroffen, ganz, ganz schlimme Sachen gesagt. Er ist ja auch ganz weirde Sachen über alleinerziehende Männer gesagt und so. Das ist ganz furchtbar. Es ist super schwierige Truppe, um anzugreifen. Wie schwierige Gendersachen gesagt, die mir nicht gefallen. Also seid vorsichtig bei Harald Schmidt. Das ist meine Watch-out-Aussage der Woche. Naja, aber ich meine, du musst natürlich besonders kritisch ihm gegenüber sein, weil diese ganze Kritik wird auch dir entgegengeschwemmt werden, wenn du mal so aussiehst wie er und dann kriegst du die Kritik natürlich direkt ins Gesicht. Wohingegen ich als Otto Walkes, komm ganz gut nach. Wirst du aussehen wie Otto Walkes? Ich glaube, ich werde aussehen wie Otto Walkes. Kann sein. Ich werde exakt so aussehen wie Otto Walkes. Wie in der Kappe vor allem, auch mit dem kleinen Hinkopter-Propeller oben drauf. Das ist aber was für dich eigentlich. Spannend. Bald Urlaub. Ich bin bald im Urlaub. Ich bin auch am... Ach ja, stimmt. Du bist komplett weg da. Nächste Woche, ne? Nächste Woche bin ich komplett weg. Wir werden natürlich weiter veröffentlichen. Ist natürlich klar, jede Woche könnt ihr euch drauf verlassen. Das Podcast UFO landet gewohnt auf eurem Handyapparat. Und ja, spannend. Ich bin gerade... Es geht campen. Ich bin gerade... Ich spiele wieder Pokémon durch. Dieses Mal nur mit Pummelow will ich es schaffen, alles durchzuspielen. Nur alleine ein Pokémon. Nur ein Pokémon und halt zwei weitere für die VMs, aber hauptsächlich kämpfen wir hier nur mit einem Pokémon. Und ja, wird spannend und ich bin gerade in so einer, ich muss noch x, x, y Sachen machen, um im Urlaub meine Ruhe zu haben und das ist die produktivste Zeit des Jahres für mich einfach. Immer so dieses, weil du denkst, je mehr ich jetzt arbeite, desto geiler wird die nächste Woche, weil du denkst, ah, das muss ich alles nicht mehr machen und ich bin gerade ultra produktiv, das heißt, falls du noch irgendwas brauchst, jetzt ist die Zeit, gibst mir, ich arbeite gerade alles weg einfach. Echt, damit du im Urlaub freien hast? Damit ich im Urlaub freien Kopf habe? Früher hatte meine Eltern eine Putzfrau und das Aufräumen für die Putzfrau war mir mein, weil ich konnte dir mein Zimmer nicht überlassen, weil es einfach aussah wie ich habe mich schlecht gefühlt, weil es so schlecht aussah, durcheinander und dann hieß es immer, die Putzfrau kommt morgen und räumt ihr das Zimmer auf und das war immer die, das war immer so, das stimmt, es ist ja auch paradox bei dir, dass der Teil, wo du dich darauf freuen sollst, dafür ursächlich ist, dass du dich doch mal richtig verausgabst mit dem autorischen Kram. Aber hast du diese Putzfrau jemals gesehen oder war das nur ein Trick deiner Eltern, dass du dein Zimmer aufräumst? Da habe ich auch lange darüber nachgedacht, ich habe sie dann irgendwann mal gesehen. Das war so ein kleiner Elf. Die sah aber sehr ähnlich aus wie deine Mutter, die hatte nur einen russischen Akzent und ansonsten sah sie genauso aus wie meine Mutter. Komischerweise. Und sie anklebt ein Schnurrbart, das war ganz seltsam. Ganz merkwürdig, ganz, ganz merkwürdige Sache, ja. Ich habe mir jetzt einen Staubsaugerroboter gekauft. Oh, ich wusste, dass das irgendwann kommt. Das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis Stefan Tieter eigentlich. Ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt schon länger, ich wollte eigentlich im Podcast darüber erzählen, weil ich deine Sprüche nicht aushalten wollte. Du, da musst du durch. Ja, das bestimmt schon auch. Insofern habe ich mir den gekauft und es ist, ich habe noch nie mehr Zeit mit Staubsaugen verbracht, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Weil, ich meine, der ist jetzt nicht der cleverste, gebe ich ganz offen zu, weiss er auch glaube ich selber, so selbstreflektiert ist er dann doch, die sind ja schon auch clever, aber nicht so clever. Jedenfalls, er fährt rum und er fährt dann immer in die Räume, wo man denkt, da hättest du bitte nicht rein, da muss es in den Raum, was muss es in den Bad, fang doch bitte in den grossen, wichtigen Räumen an. Erstmal, du bist ewig dabei, den aus irgendwelchen seltsamen Situationen zu befreien, dann ist wieder ein Klavier auf ihn gefallen oder Affen haben ihn anführt, er ist in so ganz merkwürdigen Situationen immer. Irgend so ein Stamm hat ihn zu einer Gottheit erklärt. Oh mein Gott. Da musst du irgendwelche Pesos, Lira, Gulden besorgen, um ihn rauszukaufen. Eine Kaution aus dem Gefängnis. Och Gott, dann ja. Hat er einen Namen? Sunny habe ich ihn genannt, weil er von iRobot ist. Er ist von der Marke iRobot. Wie kann man ihn nicht Sunny nennen? Von iRobot? Ist die Marke. Haben die sich die Rechte einem Film gekauft oder was? Kriegen dann noch eine kostenlose DVD dazu. Ich glaube, die haben den Film gemacht und haben dann gemerkt, oh, die Aussage war nicht die beste. Ja eben, da geht es darum, wie Roboter die Macht übernehmen. Ja, ich glaube, die haben dann auch gemerkt. Naja, ich habe dann Sunny genannt, wie den Protagonisten aus dem Film, den Roboter. Und Sunny fährt jetzt rum und ich kriege immer sehr viele SMS, dass Sunny wieder irgendwo gegen gefahren ist und Kriege in meinem Zimmer ausgelöst hat. Jedenfalls bin ich dabei, wenn ich dabei bin und er fährt, ist es halt wahnsinnig unproduktiv, weil ich bin immer dabei, gewisse Strassen zu bauen für ihn, so aus Büchern, damit er in die Räume fährt, die ich will, um ihn dann einzusperren, indem ich die Tür schnell zumache, damit er diesen Raum erstmal sauber macht.
Dann habe ich mir jetzt einen neuen Teppich gekauft, damit mein Staubsaugerroboter besser sauber machen kann, habe ich meinen alten Teppich rausgeschmissen, weil er zu hochflorig war. Leicht zu hochflorig.
Hochflorig?
Hochflorig.
Ja, was kaufst du auf einen hochflorigen Teppich?
Ich habe gesagt, hochfloriger Teppich ist schön. Ja, gut, aber jeder weiß noch, was für ein hochfloriger Teppich für Probleme mit sich bringt. Ja, hochflorig, also hochflorig, große Probleme, hochflorigen Teppich rausgeschmissen, leicht kleinflorigen Teppich rein. Niedrigflorig. Ja, mittelflorig. Reicht jedenfalls kleinflorig genug, um den Neubauter Probleme einzuschleiden zu lassen. Trotzdem finde ich mich in Situationen wieder, wo ich den einfach wieder Strassen bauen muss, damit er in die Räume fährt. Ich glaube, ich verbringe wirklich mehr Zeit mit ihm mittlerweile, auch wenn man daneben steht und guckt, was er macht. Und man schüttelt auch andere mit dem Kopf, weil man denkt, das kann nicht wahr sein. Man kann ihm nicht zugucken, weil dieses System, was er hat, dieses wogegenfahren, also mal gucken, wie lange ich in diese Richtung fahren kann. Oh, das war's, ich fahre jetzt in eine andere Richtung, gucke ich mal, wie lange ich in diese Richtung fahren kann, macht dich ja irre, weil du denkst, ach komm, ich mache schnell selber. Ich mache schnell selber. Aber ist da die Idee, dass er konstant fährt oder macht er dann so eine Stunde in der Woche oder wie viel macht er dann so? Ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass er jeden Tag mal eine Stunde fährt, aber das ist mir zu viel Arbeit, weil da musst du tendenziell häufiger mal diesen Beutel rausholen und so. Ich lasse ihn einfach einmal die Woche fahren, wenn ich ihm da bin und dann richtig. Und hast du noch einen anderen Staubsauger oder hast du den entsorgt? Nee, den habe ich noch. Du hast noch einen Ersatzstaubsauger? Ja, ja, ja. Das heißt, er steht schon ein bisschen unter Druck. Er sieht den anderen Schraubsauger auch manchmal, ja. Und du wackelst, zeigst auch manchmal so drauf. Ja, ja, und macht man immer das Geräusch nach. Ja, ich mache ja schon. Dann fährt er ein bisschen schneller, fährt er ein bisschen schneller und gibt sich ein bisschen mehr Mühe. Und er macht auch nicht so ganz doll, ich bin nicht so zufrieden, ehrlich gesagt. Also, ich bin mit Sunny nicht so zufrieden. Boss zwei. Wow. Und die dotzen dann auch gegeneinander an. Und fahren dann in andere Richtungen. Finde ich gar nicht so blöd. Wohingegen meine Mutter einen Rasenmäherroboter hat, der ist für dumm selbst zu empfehlen. Boah, das ist aber gefährlich, oder? Ich weiß nicht. Ich meine Staubsauger, ich meine selbst, wenn die Maschinen die Kontrolle übernehmen und dann deinen Staubsauger irgendwie rekrutieren in ihrer Armee. Was willst du jetzt tun? Was machst du, mich saugen oder was? Nee, was willst du jetzt tun? Willst du mich aufsaugen? So, aber ein Rasenmäher-Roboter, der macht dich kaputt. Ja. Der macht dich wirklich kaputt. Das ist ja interessant, ich habe neulich Robot Wars zum Einschlafen für mich entdeckt. Robot Wars sind ja die bekannten Turniere, meistens in Amerika, wo Hobbyteams gegeneinander antreten mit selbstgebauten Robotern, oft in so vier gegen vier Kämpfen, also vier gegen alle Kämpfen, wo in einer grossen Arena dann Roboter gegeneinander antreten, die ferngesteuert werden. Und ich dachte ja, easy, du baust einfach so einen Roboter, der so eine gross, der quasi einen Rasenmäherroboter, wo halt dieses Schneideding nach vorne gebaut ist, dass der alles wegflext, was ihm vor die Räder kommt. Mit der Theorie lag ich gar nicht so falsch. Ich dachte, die werden häufiger gebaut, es gab aber nur einen im Rennen mit dieser Säge nach vorne. Ich glaube, der Nachteil daran ist, dass der den gegnerischen Roboter halt dann eher so wegschiesst und nicht wirklich kraftanwendig aufnimmt. Ja, genau. Die sind halt gut gepanzert auch, muss man dazu sagen, deswegen ist vielleicht die Idee nicht so gut gewesen. Am Ende hat er aber auch, glaube ich, gewonnen, oder war zumindest Zweiter oder sowas. Die meisten Roboter hatten aber tatsächlich eine ganz andere Technik, langweilig wie ich fand, weil man will ja, ja, die Flipper, die einfach aussehen wie so, weiß nicht, wie dieser Mausrobot von Star Wars. Wie so ein Pfannenwender eigentlich, ein lebender Pfannenwender. Ja, und die können einfach nur dieses Geste machen und dann flippen die die Roboter vor einem halt um. Und die waren, aber teilweise waren die so brutal, dass sie die in die Höhe geworfen haben, die anderen Robotern, dass sie aufgeplatzt sind und dann flippen die die Roboter vor einem halt um. Und teilweise waren die so brutal, dass sie die in die Höhe geworfen haben, die anderen Roboter, und dass sie aufgeplatzt sind. Und dann gab es natürlich noch den Hammer, den klassischen Hammer. Und der wurde umgeflippt und konnte sich dann mit dem Hammer wieder umflippen. Da dachte ich auch, okay, du bist für mich der Sieger der Herzen. Genial. Ich habe die Sendung auch mal gesehen und ich dachte mir immer so, der eigentliche Kampf findet auf dem Parkplatz statt, oder? Eigentlich treffen die sich nach, deröhne und machen so, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, ganz schön beeindruckend, dein Flipper. In der Arena hast du dich gut gemacht, aber wie sieht's aus, halb zwölf an der alten Mühle am McDrive und dann hast du dir an die Autos vor, wo es ein Scheinwerfer liegt und dann stehen sie so im Schatten und dann haben sie nochmal so diese Steuerungsdinger in der Hand und dann machen sie sich einfach kaputt. Sind die legal, darf man damit offen rumfahren? Oder ist das so eine Art Panzer, ab wann ist man Panzer? Ab wann ist Panzer, ab wann ist Kriegsmaschine, ab wann, genau, ich weiss nicht genau, wo da die Grenze ist, das ist eine gute Frage.
Und wenn die dann irgendjemanden sehen, der irgendwie von einem Wolf angegriffen wird, würden die dann sagen so, das übernimmt jetzt Flipper und dann werfen die diesen Wolf einfach rum oder einfach den Bonk. Ja, ich weiß nicht genau. Ich glaube, der richtige Kampf danach findet vor dem grossen Mülleimer. Da wird es ja so einen grossen Mülleimer bestimmt geben, diese grossen, die man kennt, diese Rechtecke. Ja, ja. Hinter den Studios wird es ja geben, dann nachher die ganzen Verlierer kommen und ihren scheisse Roboter reinwerfen, wo dann, wo man sich nochmal kurz in die Augen guckt und denkt, ah fuck you. Ich finde auch so einen Roboter gut, der einfach nur so wirklich wie so ein Jeep ist mit so einer Pistole drauf. Einfach nur so straight und alle so ach komm und du so und ballerst die einfach weg. Und das ganze Pubum so aufsteckt einfach eine Bazooka drauf, fuck it, nur Bullshit-Handgranate das ist eh der Moment auf den man wartet einfach dass so ein Teil mal irgendwie durch die Arena durchbricht, durch die Zuschauer und einfach da ein komplettes Massaker hinterlässt, einfach überall links und rechts und dann erklär mal deiner Frau warum die beiden Kinder jetzt irgendwie beide Arme verloren haben, Das wäre blöd gelaufen, blöd gelaufen. Es sind doch nur Väter, die ihren Kindern die elektrischen Autos weggenommen haben, um dann eine Knarre draufzusetzen. Da Vinci würde wahrscheinlich mehrere Knarre in alle Richtungen draufbauen. Da Vinci würde in der ersten und dann rausfliegen. Ja, machen wir uns nichts vor. Er wird versuchen, wegzufliegen vom Parkplatz, wo sein lächerlicher Gefährt steht. Ja, wenn er sich in den Himmel schraubt. Schaut, dass er sich in den Himmel schraubt. Nix passiert ever. Man denkt ja immer so, oh, heutzutage, wenn Einstein noch mal da wäre oder Edison oder so, und dann auch jetzt mit der DNA natürlich ganz grosse Schritte gemacht, dass man sagt, kann man nicht Beethoven noch mal zurückbringen oder so. Meine grösste Angst ist, dass das einfach alles Vollidioten sind. Einfach dann bringst du so einen Vinci zurück und er einfach so, ey wir bauen einen grossen Hammer und fahren damit, ne, ne, ne, in der gegnerischen Armee, welch gegnerischen Armee, wir fahren mit dem grossen Hammer und dann macht er so BAM und dann müssen wir halt nur gucken, dass der davor nicht umfällt. Ich habe bestimmt mal eine Skizze gemacht und einfach so, ey, setz dich mal. Sein Metier war ja einfach nur Bewegung umsetzen.
Also die Bewegungsenergie drehend, umsetzen in schiebend zum Beispiel, lineare Bewegung.
Also er hat ja nur, die Grundstücke der Mechaniker hat voll gut verstanden zum Beispiel.
Aber bei...
Gut, aber die Römer haben auch schon so eine Schildkröte gebaut.
Bei Einstein bin ich mir sicher, dass er noch andere große Sachen heutzutage vollbringen würde. Meinst du? Weil er halt wirklich mit seiner Theorie der relativ... Aber bringt er... Ich weiß gar nicht, welche Relativität der Theorie war. Ich meine die... Nicht beide, speziell und allgemein? Eine war... Man sagt, eine war super zeitgeistig, also eine wäre so lag auf der Hand.
Ich kenne es aber nicht.
Die Doku, ich gucke die einmal im Monat, um mein Wissen zu refreshen, danach vergesse ich sie immer wieder.
Ich merke mir auch bei Dokus immer die falschen Sachen.
Ich auch immer.
Wenn jemand sagt, ich habe eine Doku geschaut über Napoleon, die so, ach krass, und was hat der so gemacht?
Weiss ich nicht, aber einer seiner Offiziere hatte so ein ganz weisses Pferd.
Ja, ja.
Und okay, und ja, naja, weiss ich jetzt auch nicht.
Ja, ich bin mir auch immer so random.
Habe ich mir jetzt bestellt für den Urlaub mit Biografie von Napoleon.
Das heisst, wenn ich zurückkomme, bin ich Napoleon-Expert, da kann ich mir was zählen,
mit dem guten alten Nappi kann ich euch mal ein bisschen was präsentieren. Go nappy! Great, here we go, it's a good old nappy! Zu wenig Südstaaten-Slang. Ja, es ist aber auch das Problem, wenn die heute zurückkommen, ich glaube, das wären eher so dann so Obi-Attraktionen einfach so. Wenn nappy jetzt zurück nochmal käme, irgendwie DNA-Analyse, und dann sitzt der dann halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dann irgendwie bei Genial daneben dabei oder irgendwie, bumm, die grosse Feldherrn-Show bei Sat.1, hast du einen Genghis Khan, Hitler und Napoleon. Ich sehe schon Lanz, einen Genghis Khan, Einstein und Dumm Vinci interviewen, das würde auch niemand sehen. So, und Sie wollten sich in den Himmel schrauben. Die Schraubkraft ist die Kraft, die die Menschheit noch am wenigsten
erfordert. Weggesetzt. Hin zu Biggest Loser. Zurück. Ja, Biggest Loser, wo irgendwie Buddha versucht abzunehmen oder so. Und dann einfach so im Laufball. Gott, ey, wo kommen die alle her? Dirk Bach, alle dicken Toten besonder anzunehmen. Dick und tot, die No-Show auf Satz 1. Alle Versuchungen abzunehmen, kann ich nicht wieder tot sein? Oder Dirk Bach und Johannes Paul II, Versuchungen bis ein paar Kilos abzunehmen. Und immer die awkward Gespräche zwischen den Wiegephasen immer so und einfach so Butter so, ja.
Ich finde es gut, wenn der Aufsprecher genauso trivial ist. Gespräche zwischen den Wiegephasen immer so und einfach so Buddha so, ja.
Puh, ich bin so gut, wenn der Aufsprecher genauso triviales Zeug erzählt, obwohl da einfach Buddha persönlich.
Buddha hat heute seine gelbe Badehose angezogen.
Ob er damit die Mädels beeindrucken kann.
Die Blaue ist ihm noch zu eng, hat er gesagt.
Ja, also die Blaue war mir jetzt dann doch ein bisschen eng und deswegen war richtig gelbe. Und dann auch Buddha, die Badehose zu eng. Trotzdem läuft es im Hintergrund so ein langweiliger Popsong, so ein aktueller Chartsong. Ja, ja, genau. Und dann immer so schlechte Wortwitze. Ah, Buddha will abnehmen, muss er sich dann auch in Margarine umbenennen? I can't believe it's butter. I can't believe it's Buddhism. Er war so zapped. Buddhism! Er hat so eine neue Religion gegründet direkt. Oh, das wäre nie so schlecht. Es wäre eine wilde Welt. Frauen tauschen mit so berühmten Toten. Ja. Mutter Theresa. Ja, genau. Mutter Theresa und Marie Curie. Tauschen wir ab für eine Woche. Und dann hat die überall so Chemiekram rumstehen. Kannst du doch nicht das Uran hier rumliegen lassen, das ist mein Haushalt. Mach hier was ich will, die Kinder sind verstrahlt. Ja, auch meine Kinder zu verstrahlen. Marie Curie beschwört einen grünen Energieball in ihrer Handfläche, Zap weg. Was Marie Currie heute zu Abendessen mal bastelt. Oh, Snap. Gibt es da noch lustige Songs? Ja. Ich freue mich auf diese Zeit. Ja, ich glaube, es kann nicht länger als zehn Jahre dauern. Geil! Dann wird Fernsehen endlich wieder gut. Endlich wieder geil. Du, ich glaube, die Fernsehproduzenten von heute forschen ganz aktiv an dieser DNA-Nummer, weil sie sich denken, fuck, das will auch keiner mehr sehen. Hoffentlich rufe ich uns zuerst an, wir formate Ideen. Ja, ja. The Dead Guys. Es gibt ja die Überlegung, dass man berühmte Komponisten nochmal ausgräbt, um genau festzustellen, woran die gestorben sind. Weil bei vielen weiss man nicht genau, woran die gestorben sind. Warum will man ausgerechnet, weil Komponisten wissen, wie sie gestorben sind? Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, weil man da sich denkt, ja, ich denke auch, sie ist ein bisschen drauf rumhacken, so, der ist tot und dann so, vieles gestorben trotzdem geil okay wir graben wieder ein passt ich weiß auch nicht wissenschaft wie viel prozent der wissenschaft glaubst du ist vollkommen nutzlos wie gesagt habe ich habe lange gedacht das ist alles quatsch seitdem ich meine bachelor habe geschrieben und geschrieben habe, dachte ich mir, Wissenschaft funktioniert nicht. Und wir hatten ja auch nicht unbedingt Wissenschaft, eine Bachelorarbeit über Nachmittagsfernsehen. Was existiert, ist Quatsch, weil alle wollen doch einfach fertig werden. Ja. These, alle wollen ins Bett. Richtig. Also auch die Wissenschaftler, die an einem krassen, krass rumforschen, wollen doch auch mal ins Bett. Die wollen doch primär fertig werden. Und deswegen schreibt man einfach mal Quatsch hin und so und flunkert hier und da ein bisschen und so die Quellen raus, die einem helfen. Und lässt auch mal hier, da sitzt halt Domwinci in der Staatsbibliothek Forenz und dann lässt er auch mal ein Sachen hin an den Tisch fallen, weil er sagt, das hilft mir gerade gar nicht.
Das Leben ist das.
Dieses Buch sagt quasi, dass man sich nicht in den Himmel schrauben kann. Das hilft mir gerade gar nicht.
Das ist überhaupt nicht das, was ich gerade lesen will.
Und dann gibt es schon ein Fensterglas bei uns und dann wirft er es durchs Fenster.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Es ist einfach zu schwierig. Werbung
Oh, Stefan, weißt du, was mich wirklich nervt?
Langsames Internet.
Weißt du, was mich auch am meisten nervt.
Das ist nichts nerviger als langsames Internet.
Kann man nichts dagegen machen.
Du, ich glaube, ich habe da was für uns.
Wirklich?
Ja, der Vodafone Gigacube. Der Vodafone Gigacube? Wusstest du, ohne Scheiß, wusste ich jetzt wirklich noch nicht, mal Spaß beiseite, es gibt schon 5G. Aber nur an manchen Orten. Klar, nur an manchen Orten in Deutschland, aber gibt es mittlerweile schon an manchen Orten, über das Mobilfunknetz kannst du einfach 5G bekommen. Und Vodafone Gigacube, den kannst du einfach in die Steckdose stecken, brauchst natürlich einen Mobilfunkvertrag und Handyempfang, aber dann kannst du lossurfen und hast 5G.
Du kaufst ihn einfach, steckst ihn an, brauchst keinen Techniker nicht irgendwie umständlich anschliessen, sondern du kannst direkt lossurfen, wenn du eine SIM-Karte und einen Vertrag hast.
Genau, egal, mit Smartphone, Tablet oder Notebook, also auch ideal für irgendwelche Campingurlaube.
Wenn ihr weitere Informationen wollt, geht einfach auf www.vodafone.de slash gigacube.
Und jetzt weiterhin viel Spaß mit der Folge. Und dem Gigacube. Werbung. Ich bin am Wochenende, apropos Komponisten, in Bayreuth. Oh, Bayreuth, du hast dem Rentner die Karten abgenommen, habe ich gehört. Ich habe dem Rentner die Karten geklaut. Du bist in Bayreuth bei den Wagner-Festspielen. Man muss ja sagen, dass das sehr schwierig ist, da an Karten zu kommen. Und ich habe eine Ebay-Kleinanzeigen-Annonce gestartet, ein Gesuch, in dem ich schreibe, dass ich eine Karte suche. Und mich hat ein weinender Opa angerufen, der irgendwie konnte er nicht mehr dahin, Er ist seit Jahren in dieser Lotterie und seit Jahren in dieser virtuellen Warteschlange, steht seit Jahren an für dieses Ticket, hat es jetzt bekommen und kann nicht und hat es mir dann verkauft für den Originalpreis. Wie, kann nicht, wofür, warum kann er nicht, was kommt da dazwischen? Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, ja. Was kommt da dazwischen? Ich habe es eigentlich vergessen. Irgendwas dazwischen gekommen, gemeinsamer Urlaub mit Freunden oder sowas, also irgendwas, wo er dann nicht nein sagen konnte.
Tat mir dann sehr leid, er hat zwar mir vermacht und jetzt die andere Karte, weil ich das ja niemanden gefunden habe, der sich für diesen Preis dann doch noch finden konnte. Du sitzt dir direkt gegenüber.
Du warst im Urlaub, du bist Campen.
Der Bock hat auf Wagner, viereinhalb Stunden und Bayreuth vor allem und Übernachtungen und all diesen Scheiss.
Habe ich niemanden gefunden und deswegen war ich alleine hin und sitze in einer Loge neben einem Fremden. Wie, Moment, aber hast du die Karte dann verkauft? Die andere Karte verkauft, ja. Und du wirst den erst kennenlernen, wenn du neben ihm sitzt? Wir haben schon geschrieben, es sind schon Mails hin und her geflossen. Ist das nicht ein bisschen unangenehm, wenn man, grüßt man sich dann? Ja klar, man grüßt sich. Ja? Man redet doch wahrscheinlich in der Pause oder so. Es gibt zwei Pausen. Oh Gott, ey, das würde mir fast das ganze Ding versauen, dass ich dann weiß. Nee, so schlimm ist es bei mir noch nicht. Nee? Noch nicht? Noch nicht. Aber da sind doch dann auch, da ist ja schon mal Thomas Gottschalk dabei und so. Ich glaube, bei der Premiere sind die alle. Dieses Jahr ist ja ein grosses Tannhä Jahr wird neu aufgelegt ich sehe die Meistersinger von Nürnberg bin ich gespannt habe ich noch nie gesehen ich freue mich sehr darauf jedenfalls ich bin wie gesagt großer Wagner-Fan der Musik der Musik nicht des Huts der Hut seines Bartes ist nicht das was mich fasziniert sein Bart fasziniert mich nicht. Ich bin Fan seiner Musik und seiner Gesinnung. Mehr nicht. Grosse Kontroverse um seinen Hut. Damit habe ich nichts zu tun. Damit will ich nichts zu tun haben. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Dankeschön, ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich freue mich da drauf. Und dann schön mit Frack, oder was? Schön richtig? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, es reicht ein Anzug. Wie gesagt, es ist nicht die Premiere. Wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben. Weißt du mal, wenn du dich für irgendwas anziehst, dann für die Wagner-Festspiele in Bayreuth, da kannst du nicht mit der Jong-Yohse kommen. Wobei es im Internet stand, es wurden auch schon Leute mit kurzen Hosen gesehen, sagt auch niemand mehr was. Und die meisten Leute nehmen sich ja selber ein, und da habe ich wirklich Angst vor, weil es ja so ein uraltes Theater, was sich niemand traut anzufassen, weil die Akustik so eins zu eins der besten Akustiken der Welt zählt, traut sich niemand dieses Theater anzufassen, sei es mit modernen Stühlen auszustatten oder ein bisschen komfortabler zu machen. Damals waren die Leute halt kleiner. Also ich habe wirklich massive Probleme, werde ich haben und du sitzt auf Hartholz halt viereinhalb Stunden. Wie viele Leute waren kleiner vor hundert Jahren? Waren Leute deutlich kleiner, ja. Deutlich kleiner, deutlich kleiner. Deutlich kleiner, merklich kleiner. Wow. Sichtlich, sichtbar kleiner. Werden wir noch grösser momentan? Das weiss ich nicht, ich bin so ein bisschen der lebende Beweis, aber ich weiss es noch nicht. Du bist der Mensch der Zukunft, alle werden grösser. Ja. Krass. Ja, genau, jetzt werde ich da viereinhalb Stunden eingepfercht sitzen, zwischen ganz kleinen Stuhlreihen auf Hartholz und werde Musik lauschen. Dafür ist die Akustik atemberaubend, umwerfend, bezaubernd. Freue ich mich drauf. Orchester ist natürlich feinste Sahne. Ja, du musst natürlich auch mal ins Publikum gucken, weil da alles da ist. Also da will ich jetzt schon ein bisschen Promi-Gossip haben, wenn du das nächste Mal kommst. Sieh mal ein Mikrofon mit, dann vielleicht krieg ich jemanden vors Mikro für das Popf in den Podcast. Karl Loth sitzt dann da irgendwie und P.M. Krause daneben und dann, oh, geht da was und so. Also da will ich wirklich schon pikantes, pikantes Schnüffeln von Stefan Tietze nächste Woche haben. Ja, ich versuch P.M. Krause vors Mikrofon zu bekommen. Mach der mal, und frag mal Christian Thielemann, ob er in den Podcast kommen will, ohne Scheiss. Der ist nicht der Dirigent meines Abends. Ja, aber der hängt doch da rum, der hängt doch am Buffet rum. Der hängt da ab. Ich will noch einen Gast fürs Podcast-Ufo, ich will noch die Christian Thielemann-Folge machen. Ja, würde ich sehr gerne machen. Fände ich absolut grossartig. Wir würden ihn einfliegen, ne, einen fahren lassen und dann alles andere übernehmen wir. Genau Thiedemann hier. Das wäre nicht großartig. Wenn jemand von euch Christian Thiedemann kennt. Man kann ja in einem Musikladen, einem gut sortierten Musikladen kann man sich einen Dirigierstock kaufen. Nicht im Ernst. Ja klar, die muss man ja auch irgendwo haben. Einen Baton? Einen Dirigierstock, wo ich mir auch denke, diese Kiste, ich war in so einem Musikladen, da hatten sie eine Kiste Dirigierstöcke, eine Kiste, wo bestimmt 200 drin waren. Hast du auch gekauft? Ne, da waren 200 drin, wo ich mir dachte, wie lange hält diese Kiste, wie viele Dirigierstöcke verkaufen die so pro Woche? Ach so. Wie lange mussten die die Kiste schon mal nachstocken, wir brauchen noch Dirigierstöcke hinten nachbestellen und leider keine Dirigierstöcke mehr. Dann muss ich wohl meinen Harry-Potter-Zauberstab von Ginny nehmen. Den können sie nicht nehmen. Wie? Dann verspielen die sich. Die sind verboten worden, als einer mal angegangen ist. Wie in der Vorstellung war es ein riesen Problem. Ach so, aus Versehen ex pecto patronum. Richtig, und dann fängt das Orchester an. Dann kommst du doch nicht mehr raus. Ja, klar.
Das Publikum singt mit und dann hält es niemand mehr auf.
Halten die Fresse.
Die Musiker auch alle a cappella.
Grossartig.
Toller, toller Song.
Ich habe letztens, gebe ich auch ganz ehrlich zu, habe ich Twilight gesehen, habe mir nochmal Twilight angeschaut. Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da Oder sowas. Und die Idee ist ja, dass es Vampire sind, Spoiler, und die haben ja was gegen Sonnenlicht, die dürfen nicht ins Sonnenlicht. Deswegen sind die irgendwo hingezogen, wo es den ganzen Tag Wolken behangen ist. Ergibt durchaus Sinn. Das wolltest du haben. Und deswegen hat der Film auch diese leicht melancholische, traurige Stimmung, irgendwie so trostlos ein bisschen. Und manchmal habe ich genau Bock darauf, irgendwie so, auf dieses Wald verhangener, bewölbter Wald Wenn ich mir meinen Kunstkonsum an, meine Kunstrezeption anschaue, ist es meistens etwas, was mich uplifting, also uplifting art. Also Filme, die einen gut drauf kommen werden lassen, Musik, die gut drauf macht. Du warst ja jetzt, sag ich mal, im Call-me-by-your-name-Setting gerade unterwegs, im Urlaub. Stimmt. Ja, Call-me-by-your-name ist aber auch wahnsinnig aufhellend. Ja, das will ich nicht sagen. Doch, finde ich schon. Doch, also man will ja schon, das war wirklich wahnsinnig schön. Ich will ja in Toskana, was nicht die Gegend ist, sehr Norditalien, eher Lombardei ist das ja, wo Call-me-by-your- Name spielt. Toskana ist ja dann eher ein bisschen südlicher, noch ein bisschen wärmeres Gefilde. Das sind so drei Rivieras entfernt, glaube ich. Paar Rivieren entfernt. Und es ist ganz schön da. Also es war wirklich, also teilweise was so die Läden angeht und so, schon wie im Film, auch diese kleinen verlassenen Städtchen und so, war schon cool. Und schöne ital italienische Küche genossen, schöne Gnocchi, Cappuccino, Tatschla Telle. Ich war tatsächlich in einem supercoolen Laden in Florenz, ein supercooles Restaurant, was mir empfohlen wurde als Restaurantführer, war jemand, ich kenne jemanden, der bezahlt für Restaurantführer, und dann gibt es ja quasi die Sterneküche, die Sternegastro, und es gibt aber auch die sehr gute Gastronomie, die keine Sterne haben, weil es einfach, weil Sterne ja nicht unbedingt nur die besten Restaurants auszeichnen, sondern auch einfach Leute, Restaurants mit einem krassen edgy Konzept etc. Das heißt, manche sehr, sehr gute Restaurants haben keine Sterne, weil die es erst gar nicht versuchen, weil die einfach trotzdem in Breite ... Eine schöne Dönerbude einfach. Küche haben wollen. Extrem guter Döner, aber halt langweilig. Richtig, exakt, in Florenz sind das nicht Döner, sondern halt Sandwiches. Diese krassen Gastroführer empfehlen extrem viele Sandwich-Läden. Auch eine ganz tolle Empfehlung, habe ich von einer Hörerin von uns bekommen, auch in Florenz. Es gibt ganz tolle Sandwiches-Läden, auch zum Beispiel Casa del Vino ist ein ganz kleines, ganz kleiner Laden, wo nur Italiener waren, aber dann war der Laden noch voll mit fünf Italienern. Du konntest dann nur stehen, essen, super unangenehm, super klein, so ein ganz kleiner oller Laden, aber perfekte Sandwiches mit frischem Prosciutto und Tattufo und Mozzarella. Und das war dann schon echt lecker. Und da war ich auch abends echt schön essen, in einem Laden, wo links von mir Amerikaner saßen und rechts von mir Amerikaner saßen. Und dann hat man auch keinen entspannten Abend, weil die Amerikaner halt sofort einen anquatschen. Ah ja. Ich mag es ja ganz gerne, aber es ist wirklich interessant, dass es so eine andere Kultur ist. In Deutschland würden die das alle für sich selber essen, natürlich. Und Amerikaner sofort fragen, und was habt ihr heute gemacht, wo kommt ihr her? Das war schon lustig. Ich bin mittlerweile echt so weit, ich bin weit ich bin da was das angeht dass der deutscheste deutschland es gibt ja ich bin mittlerweile so weit dass ich nicht mal mehr alleine esse sondern to go nehme um mich draußen irgendwo alleine hinzusetzen dass es mir nicht mal mehr reicht in einem restaurant allein zu sitzen sondern ich will sogar einfach räumlich ganz alleine woanders sein irgendwo auf einer bank oder so ich habe nach wie vor ein unbehagen, alleine draußen irgendwo zu essen, weil es in mir, ich weiß nicht, woher das liegt, weil ich auch als Einzelkind isst so halt oft allein und so, also eigentlich, also sozial sollte es mir nichts bedeuten, so bin ich nicht sozialisiert, aber ich glaube, es ist so ein Urinstinkt, man isst halt im Stamm herum. Ich weiß nicht, ob es so eine Angst ist, von einem Raubtier angegriffen zu werden. Ja, kann sein. Dass es mir weggenommen wird oder sowas. Oder dass, falls du dich verschluckst, kann niemand helfen? Vielleicht sowas. Auf jeden Fall, ich sass häufig irgendwo in letzter Zeit alleine rum und habe gegessen und dachte mir, das ist nicht, das kann ich nicht. Für mich der Inbegriff von Freiheit ist zu essen und währenddessen was anderes machen. Währenddessen einen Podcast zu hören, ein Video anzuschauen, einen Film zu schauen und währenddessen zu essen, das ist für mich fantastisch. Ja, ich esse aber auch immer das währenddessen. Und das kann man ja nur alleine machen, weil da kannst du nicht hier sitzen. Und teilweise ist es wirklich so, dass ich mit dem Essen dann vor dem Rechner sitze und dann das perfekte Video suche, wo ich mir denke, ich brauche jetzt das perfekte Video für dieses Essen, damit ich anfangen kann zu essen. Oft kann ich nicht anfangen zu essen, bevor ich nicht das perfekte Video habe. Und das ist dann genau das, was ich brauche. Ja, interessant. Schöne Nudeln mit Jalapeno. Nudeln mit Jalapeno? Weißt du gerade dein Go-To-Gericht eigentlich? Mein Go-To-Gericht seit langer, langer Zeit sind eben diese Asiennudeln, die ich angesprochen habe, wo ich mich immer mit dem Asiaten darum kämpfe, jede Woche aufs Neue. Mittlerweile habe ich ein bisschen Vorsprung, habe ich glaube ich schon so 30, 40 Packungen bei mir zu Hause.
Ja, weil der Asialle selber diese asiatische Nudel nicht mehr ertragen kann.
Mag sein, mag sein. Die koche ich immer schön aus, dass das Wasser rausgekocht ist, dass es schön schleimig ist und dann, wenn die schleimigen Nudeln fertig sind, dann habe ich noch ein Extrateller mit Jalapenos und dann tue ich immer ein paar Nudeln auf meine Gabel, stocher dann mit der Gabel noch eine Jalpeño auf, rote Jalapeño, weil das ist nicht anders, aufgestochert und dann... Grossartig. Chilischoten. Ja, was Rotes. Man sagt gern Jalapeño, ne? Man sagt Jalapeño. Man sagt das gern. Jalapeño. Glaubst du, man isst manche Sachen auch lieber, weil man sie gerne ausspricht? Auf jeden Fall, und ich finde ja auch das Phänomen interessant, dass manche Begriffe übersetzt werden und andere nicht. Also du sagst zum Beispiel Tartufo, du sagst aber nicht Parmigiano, du sagst Parmesan. Das ist auch Trüffel, sagst du auch. Ach, Tartufo ist, nee, Tartufo ist Trüffel? Tartufo ist Trüffel, ja. Nee, Tartufo ist doch diese Nachspeise. Nee, das ist Tiramisu. Nee, es gibt aber auch Tartufo. Ne, nicht gerade, was du meinst, wenn man so eine Nachspeise so heißt, kann sein. Tattufo ist Trüffel, das ist das italienische Wort, Trüffel. Ah, okay, gut. Aber es gibt ja irgendwas, keine Ahnung, Cappuccino übersetzt man nicht. Cappuccino sagt man Cappuccino, aber man sagt Parmesan, obwohl Cappuccino auch nicht so leicht aussieht, ja gut, okay. Aber es ist interessant, manche Werte werden übersetzt.
Manche Städtenbenamen werden übersetzt, manche nicht. In Italien haben wir uns entschieden, alles zu übersetzen. Neapel, Florenz, Rom, nichts davon sagen Italiener, es ist Roma, Neapel ist, weiß ich es auch nicht, Neapel wahrscheinlich, aber Ferenze ist Florenz. So in New York waren wir, ich war schon in San Francisco, Los Angeles, sind alles Wörter, die wir sagen, die werden nicht mehr übersetzt.
Vielleicht liegt es ein bisschen an der Zeit, wann diese Städte gegründet wurden und gross waren.
Das stimmt schon, das macht man nicht mehr.
Aber es ist ein bisschen interessant, Madrid ist in Madrid, es denn spanische Städte, die übersetzt werden? Ich glaube nicht. Italienische Städte werden fast immer übersetzt. Malotze. Venedig. Malotze. Malotze wird übersetzt. Ja. Aber ich glaube, gibt es eine... Du, ich kann dir zwei spanische Städte nennen. Ich bin völlig... Mit Spanien kenne ich mich überhaupt nicht aus. Aber ich glaube, italienisch ist das eine bisschen Ausnahme. Italien übersetzt man die Städte. Ja, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung. Stimmt, in Frankreich auch nicht. Bordeaux, Paris. Nee, genau, aber in Italien ist es halt Venedig. Ist es nur Italien vielleicht? Ja, das glaube ich auch gerade. Ja, ich meine, man sagt London statt London, aber es ist trotzdem das gleiche. Ja, ich glaube, es ist ausschließlich Italien, wo man sich entschieden hat, nö, die übersetzen wir alle. Wieso das denn? Das ist ja noch nie aufgefallen. Du hast recht. Nö, es ist Venedig. Nö, aber Russland oder so sagt man auch Moskau und Sankt Petersburg und so, das glaube ich, so heißen die in Russland nicht.
Das glaube ich doch.
Ja?
Es ist nur halt in diesem kyrillischen Alphabet anders. Es gab ja so Städte wie Danzig oder so, die jetzt anders heißen.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja dann auch eine andere Stadt geworden.
Königsberg, ja genau.
Von der, von der Stimmung.
Genau, aber ich glaube, Italien ist das einzige Land, wo man gesagt hat, wie weißt du, das n nennen wir jetzt alles anders. Kapstadt vielleicht? Ist das wegen diesem alten Römer gegen Germanen-Ding noch? Dass man sagt, nee, den lassen wir nicht ihre Städte nahmen. Ja, ja, nicht den irgende, ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, das wird mal irgendwann uns gehören, das nennen wir mal schön hier Venedig. Und dann hat irgend so ein Chefgermane so eine Liste auf dem Schreibtisch bekommen, so und jetzt übersetzt mal die Namen. Hier, Rom, Roma. Was ist Roma? Machen wir Rom. Rom. Rom. So, Napoli. Neabel. Neabel. Neabel. Neabel. So, das war, das war ein ganzer Monat ist da reingeflossen. Bei Bologna hat man dann gesagt, nee, Bologna. Nee, Bologno. Bologna bleibt Bologna. Schön Bolognese, lecker. Oh jetzt mache ich ja mal Pause, immer am Mittag, jetzt Bolo. Schön Bolo, holo Bolo rein. Oh lecker. Bologna ist Bolo? Ja, Bolo. Ja, aber das finde ich wirklich interessant. Muss man mal herausfinden, warum das Lied. Das ist, das ist kein. Wenn uns Italiener zuhören, können die mal Bescheid sagen. Wogegen Deutsche steht da auch ein Land übersetzt werden, ins Ausland. Colonia, Cologne, Hanover, ein N, nimmt man ein N weg, warum? Munich, Nuremberg. Ist das so ein reindeutsches Ding, gibt es auch einen englischen Begriff für Paris? Nee, es gibt einen englischen Begriff für Cologne und Köln, aber es gibt keinen für Paris oder Italienisch. Aber auch Italienisch. Nee, Rome, R-O-M-E sagt man ja auch. Naples sagen die auch. Rome, stimmt. Die sagen Rome, die sagen Naples, Venice, Vienna. Nee. Bei Venice. Bei Einländern ist es ganz einfach. Ja, Vienna, du hast recht. Also im Ausland, ich glaube, im Ausland ist es verbreiteter, eher die Städtennamen zu ändern sogar. Deutsche Städte werden ständig verändert, Italienisch ist bei allen Ländern. Ich bin maximal verwirrt gerade, ich komme da nicht mehr raus. Lass uns einfach mal eine Regel, was wird übersetzt und was nicht. Und lass uns einfach Städtenamen mal nicht übersetzen, das ist Quatsch. Lass uns die doch einfach mal durchnummerieren, Freunde. Ich habe auch immer Firenze gesagt, das sind auch alle aufgeregt. Jede Stadt hat bereits eine Postleitzahl, lass uns die doch verwenden. Hey, letztens war ich in 10114, direkt über 10118. Oh ja, soll so schön sein. 10118 im Sommer ist so. Soll so schön sein, ja, weisst du, wo ich unbedingt mal hin will? 64,2,2,8.
Nee, da zieht mich ja gar nichts hin.
Wirklich, nee, aber ich will unbedingt schon mal hin.
Letztens dachte ich mir, es ist ein bisschen zu teuer, aber ich habe da ein ganz tolles Angebot bekommen, wo ich mir dachte, 64,2,2,8, fährst du hin?
Nee, nee, nee, du bist unter acht Stunden Reise.
Nicht im Ernst.
Wirklich, ja, doch, die haben jetzt so ein neues Flugzeug.
Mit wem fliegst du?
Ja, 4,4,9. Klar, ist doch klar. Naja, es läuft halt ganz gut. Und wir dachten jetzt, ja, warum nicht mal. Ja, sehr gut. Ich weiß nicht, wir kommen noch nicht weiter, wir müssen da mal dringend irgendwelche Leute befragen. Wir müssen einiges ändern, wir brauchen eine neue Regierung, die mal irgendwie diese ganzen Politikscheiss sein lässt und mal sowas macht. Und einfach mal, wir brauchen neue Zahlen, wir brauchen neue Monate, wir brauchen neue Sternen, der grosse Wagen, das langweilt mich so. Jeden Tag musst du dich mit diesen scheissbegriffen rumkämpfen, wo man einfach mal sagt, das sieht hinten vorne nicht aus wie ein Bär. Das müsste man wieder um nennen. Wenn man mit Goodwill-Trapez zum Beispiel. Oder in Anführungszeichen Trapp oder ein Bär. Ein Wenn's hoch kommt Dreieck. So, das ist doch mehr nichts. Das ist die Revolution, die wir brauchen. Nicht immer dieser Quatsch mit Steuern hoch, Steuern hoch, Steuern runter, mir doch egal. Neue Ordnung. Ja, meine neue Ordnung. Neue Sachlichkeit, finde ich gut. Wir brauchen eh eine Weltregierung. Es gab ja Ideen für eine Weltregierung. Ich glaube, auch während der französischen Revolution gab es einige, da gab es ja viele verschiedene Strömungen. Aber dann nicht die, wir sind die Weltregierung? Ja, wir waren ja die Ersten so irgendwie von diesen ganzen Ideen, Gedanken gut. Und dann war die Idee und dann hatte einer gesagt, ja, alle schliessen uns jetzt an, Stück für Stück. Und irgendwann gibt es halt nur noch ein Land auf der Welt. Alle schliessen sich Frankreich an, das kann man dann irgendwann umbenennen halt in Weltreich oder so. Und dann Erdi, Erdi. Und dann kann man irgendwann schliessen alle an. Also es gab wirklich Leute, die davon ausgegangen sind, dass so jetzt haben wir es geschafft, diesen ganzen scheiß Länderkram zu beenden, jetzt machen wir eine grosse Weltregierung und dann bist du da die Hymne hast. Boah, ich will meine Harfe mit drin haben. Bei der Hymne, wenn Frankreich die Weltregierung bildet, gibt's bei der Hymne keine Diskussion. Ne, Massiers ist das? Alle können sich auf die Massiers einigen.
Ja, ist schon die beste eigentlich. Super blutiger Text, der kommt der Schwerte.
Oh, nicht schlecht, sehr gut. Ja, okay, die Amerikaner kriegen es mal wieder. Der Ende wird es ja. Free. Das ist zu hoch. Wahnsinnig schwer zu singen. Und da gibt es ja diese tolle Metapher von, ich weiß nicht, wer die aufgestellt hat, irgendein berühmter schwarzer Menschenrechtler hat den USA auch mal gesagt, dass es sehr bezeichnend dafür ist, dass bei der Nationalhymne das Wort free so hoch ist, dass niemand es singen kann. Wow. Und das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Nur die Frauen singen. Schaut euch mal die, nee, nicht mal die eigentlich, nur trainierte Frauen können, trainierte drei Sängerinnen und Sänger können, die das Hohe, weiss ich nicht, was das ist, treffen. Krass, das ist zu schwer, das ist zu schwer.
Oh, so sind Drum and Bass-Hymnen.
Ich weiss sogar, wenn alle so gut singen könnten, dass sie automatisch transponieren im Stadion. The land of the free. Und das einfach transponieren und den Okabe tiefer, dass sie den hohen Ton singen, diesen einen hohen Ton. Das wäre auch weird. Gut, dann haben wir die Hymne ja jetzt abgeschlossen, wunderbar. Währung. Wir haben diese Münzen mit Loch drin, wir haben die eckigen Münzen, wir haben noch eine Idee von dem jungen, sehr engagierten Republikaner in der ersten Reihe, ja?
Keine Münzen.
Ein Raunen ging durch die Versammlung, alle vierhundertsechzigtausend Abgeordneten der Weltregierung waren schockiert über den Vorschlag des jungen Republikaners in der ersten Reihe.
Ich habe überlegt, brauchen wir überhaupt das Prinzip des Geldes?
Ein erneutes Raun, die Luft wird langsam knapp.
Aber auch der Junge hatte keine besonderlich gute Idee in der Hinterhand.
Er wollte nur Zeit schinden.
Er wollte nur Zeit schinden, damit sein verarmter Bruder durch die Reihen gehen kann und den Leuten das Geld aus den Taschen ziehen kann.
Denn ich habe mir überlegt, ist Besitz
nicht eh für den Arsch?
Man braucht doch keinen
Besitztümer. Wo ist mein Geld, boah?
Wenn wir alle...
Entschuldigung, mal ganz kurz.
Sie durften auch ausreden.
Wenn alle nichts haben,
haben dann nicht alle viel.
Weil dann muss der nichts mehr. Wow. Argentinien, könnten Sie bitte den ironischen Kommentar zurückziehen? Ja, lass ich streichen. Bitte argentinischen Kommentar aus dem Protokoll streichen. Weil dann ist das doch clever, wenn dann hat niemand mehr was und wir alle haben ein gutes Leben, so bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen. Ja, dann gib doch deine Schuhe her. Ja, dann gib mir doch mal Geld für deine Schuhe. Okay, ich gebe dir 100 Mark für die Schuhe. Nee, ich nehme nur Pfund an. Wir haben uns auf D-Mark geeinigt. Die Weltregierung hat D-Mark. Was ist da eigentlich schiefgelaufen? Ich bin vor allem so sau auf meinen Bruder gerade, dass er dir das Geld nicht abgenommen hat. Alter. Die schöne D-Mark. Wir haben uns auf die D-Mark geeinigt. Das war so eine hässliche Währung, muss man auch mal echt sagen. Ja, mit Gauss? Ich fand es so geil, dass Gauss auf dem Zehner war. Ja, Zehner? Gauss, ey, fand ich grossartig. Nicht beschwören können. Doch, Gauss finde ich gut, ein Land, das ein Mathematiker auf dem Zehn-Mark-Schein hat. Und mein Vater hat mir immer erzählt, wie Gauss gerechnet hat mit dem eins plus zwei plus drei plus vier, hat er mir die Geschichte erzählt, dass Gauss war zu klug in der Klasse und er hat immer alle Aufgaben zu schnell gemacht und dann hat der Lehrer gesagt, so, jetzt kriegt der Gauss mal eine ganz schwere Aufgabe, damit der Rest der Stunde still ist, rechne doch mal aus, eins plus zwei plus drei plus vier bis hundert Und der Gauss in kürzester Zeit rechnet das aus, richtiges Ergebnis.
Und der Lehrer völlig verzweifelt, das kann doch nicht sein, ey, der Junge, der rechnet mir alles weg. Wie hast du das denn so schnell berechnet? Und hat er gesagt, ja, er hat sich das wie eine grosse Kette vorgestellt und hat die einmal in der Mitte zusammengeklappt. Und dann hat er ja 100 plus 1, 99 plus 2, 98 plus 3 ergibt immer 101 und davon insgesamt 50 Paare, also 101 mal 50, 5050, zack, Lösung, bam. Und dann hat der Lehrer gesagt, weißt du was, du kommst jetzt mal auf den 10-Mark-Schein und dann hältst du mal einfach deine scheiß Fresse, du Depp. Und dann hat er gesagt, so, wenn du die Fresse hältst, ich habe euch gesagt, wenn du die Fresse hältst, dann ländert du einen 10 Mark Schein. Oh man, das war eine Art Strafe, das war eine Art Strafe. Alle fassen mich an und ziehen Koks durch mich. Schön Gauss auf dem 10er. Schön Gauss auf dem 10er. Wer war denn der Wehrde auf dem 50er eigentlich? Rechte das mal Gausshner. Wer war denn der Weider auf dem Fünfziger eigentlich? Echt dir das mal Gauss? Wow. Wer war denn der Weider auf dem Fünfziger denn mit den langen Locken? Bach. Nee, das war nicht Bach. Das ist irgendein so ein weirder Typ. Es ist ultra schwer. Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin 94 geboren, ich erinnere mich gar nicht. Stimmt, ja. Ich erinnere mich gar nicht an D-Mark, leider mehr. Aber es ist mir, glaube ich, die drei Jahre voraus. Ich glaube, der Euro hat es da schon richtig gemacht, weil es ist schon schwer, einen Personenkreis von zehn Leuten festzulegen, die auch bestenfalls in 30, 50, 100 Jahren noch relevant sind.
Und klar, heute sagst du Elon Musk, irgendwie Ronald McDonald, irgendwie J.Lo und Pumpkin und druckst dir und in 100 Jahren denkst du wer, wer ist das, das ist ein Comichund, das ist Snoopy, sag mir gar nichts, die sind einfach scheiße. Ja, jetzt sind es Brücken auf den Scheinen, oder? Aber Fantasiebrücken, die existieren nicht. Aber genau, die existieren nicht. Ne, die existieren nicht. Weird auch, aber weird Entscheidung. Super weird. Wo auch jeder Künstler der Brücken malt, denkt, warum nicht meine Brücken? Ja, besser als nichts. Ich glaube, in Kanada ist es viel auch Tiere, die haben dann so den Elch. Kanada hat diese ganze weirde Monopoly-Geld. Die auch riechen, ne? Das kanadische Geld riecht nach Ahornsirup. Ja, wirklich, die haben da, glaube ich, so ein Scratch-and-Sniff-Ding da auf. Ich glaube, da wurde so falsch. Doch, doch, doch, doch. Kennst du Scratch-and-Sniff-Sticker? Scratch-and-Sniff, ja, großer Fan von der Diddle Scr der Diddle Scratch and Sniff Papiere damals. Ah ja, ich hatte immer nur die Simpsons Sticker, da gab es auch manche Scratch and Sniff Sticker. Waren nicht alle Scratch and Sniff? Manche aber schon, ich mag einfach Scratch and Sniff. Auch weil man es gerne sagt. Man sagt gerne Scratch and Sniff. Scratch and Sniff. Scratch and Sniff. Und du weißt auch einfach, hey, was muss ich da machen? Scratch and Sniff. So unsere GbR nennen sollen. Scratch and Sniff. Scratch and Sniff. Dieenne es und will. Scratch and Sniff. Schon, ne? Scratch and Sniff. Klingt ein bisschen grossartiger. Also falls ihr noch auf der Suche nach einem Bandnamen seid, greift zu. Scratch and Sniff ist glaube ich... Scratch and Sniff. Ihr macht so Hardcore-Beat. Das war ja wirklich der erste ambitionierte Versuch, Geruch als Medium zu etablieren. Scratch and Sniff. So, weil du hast ein Buch. Du könntest ja ein Buch machen, wo du auf jeder Seite noch so einen Scratch and Sniff hast und dann kannst du was riechen. Und ich glaube, es gab auch einen Kinofilm oder es gab irgendeine Film Pioniere, die gesagt haben, der mit Duft spielen wollte? Genau, und der hat dann mit Scratch and Sniff gearbeitet. Ich bilde mir immer ein, wenn man eine Szene hat, du hast gerade auch von Stimmung gesprochen im Film, wenn du eine Szene hast, wo Regen auf Asphalt, auf warmen Asphalt tröpfelt, dass man das riecht. Ich bilde mir das immer ein. Es gibt so manche Szenen, auch bei Common by Your Name ist so ein fantastischer Film, dass ich mir dann denke, man riecht es förmlich. Gleich braucht man es ja gar nicht, weil man die, irgendwie, durch Assoziionen einfach trotzdem hinkommt. Ich glaube nicht, weil ich glaube, Gerüche sind ja auch, ist ja eine Art Medium, wenn man es so bezeichnen will, was dermassen stark Erinnerungen auslöst wie kein anderes, weil die Nervenbahnen wohl so eng verknüpft sind, das habe ich mal gehört. Deswegen, wenn du Dinge riechst, kannst du dich besser an Dinge erinnern. Du kannst dich über Erinnerungen besser als über jeden anderen Sinn an Dinge erinnern. Ey, zum Glück sind Erinnerungen nicht neben Fühlen. Dass du dir nicht nur an daran erinnern kannst, wenn du sie fühlst. Oh, wie widerlich das wäre. Dass du jedem ins Gesicht tatschen musst. Ja. Würdest du sagen, von dir hast du einen guten Körpergeruch, einen angeheben Körpergeruch? Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht. Also manchmal verlasse ich meine Wohnung und komme wieder zurück und denke mir, naja. Ich habe jetzt gefragt, weil wenn ich abends in mein Bett falle, in mein Bettchen falle, besonders in meinen Kissen, Heier, in meine Heier und mein Kissen, wo ich immer jede Nacht drauf schlafe, dann liegt mein Eines Kissen, das mir ins Gesicht presse und daran rieche, denke ich mir, es gibt keinen schöneren Geruch auf der Welt.
Ist es, bin ich das?
Ich?
Ja, ist das mein Narzissmus?
Also riecht jeder Mensch seinen Körpergeruch am liebsten oder rieche ich einfach fantastisch?
Das ist meine Frage.
Du riechst sehr fantastisch, aber ich glaube auch, dass man seinen eigenen Geruch in I gerade nicht riecht, weil du kannst ja...
Doch, ich rieche ja meinen Körpergeruch. Ja, aber du siehst... Das ist ja genauso, wie dass du deine Nase nicht sehen kannst, weil dein Gehirn es einfach rausrechnet. Und genauso ist dein Geruch auch... Aber ich rieche ja etwas, wenn ich an diesem Kissen rieche. Ja, dann riechst du dann irgendwie die Federn da drin oder das Waschmittel oder so. Nee, aber alle Dinge, die ich... Früher hatte ich ein Schnuffeltuch. Früher hatte ich lange Zeit, als ich zwei Jahre alt war, hatte ich lange bis drei, jetzt sehr lange. Das war dein Onkel. Hatte ich so ein Schnuffeltuch. Das habe ich auch immer, wenn du es gewaschen musst, und dann habe ich es gehasst. Und dann habe ich es lange wieder gehabt, und dann habe ich es immer in der Hand gehabt. Gibt es nicht an, von Schienerz? Schnuffeltuch? Also habe ich es mal genannt. Ich habe es noch nie davon erzählt. Aber das war einfach ein normales Tuch und du hast einfach dann gerochen ab und zu. Ich glaube, dass Kinder haben so ein Spucktuch. Und jetzt habe ich irgendwann Zweckentfremdet und das war so ein kuscheliges Tuch. Du meinst ein Letzchen oder was? Ja, so ein kuscheliges Letzchen. Ne, das war schon so ein Tuch. Das hatte ich immer in der Hand. Ein Spucktuch? Einer von den Peanuts hat auch ein Schnuffeltuch. Das ist ein Handtuch. Ne, so war es aber. Aber es war kein Handtuch. Das ist eine Dec. Das war es auch nicht, wie so ein Tüchchen. Es war ein dünneres Tuch halt. Es war ein Schnuffeltuch. Es klingt super und auch ein Bandname wie der ein nach dem anderen. Schnuffeltuch. Schnuffeltuch. Ich habe es gehasst, sobald es gewaschen wurde. Und erst, wenn es wieder meinen Geruch angenommen hat, habe ich es geliebt.
Ist es mein Blanken, bin ich der Einzige, da liebe ich mich so sehr selber.
Ey, wir machen glaube ich eine eigene Dating-App auch für Leute, die Schnuffeltücher hatten, glaube ich. Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz besonderer Schlagmensch.
Ich denke mir einfach, da habe ich ja auch noch etwas gerochen. Das riecht er dann auch, hat er dann angefangen nach mir zu riechen.
Aber riecht es halt nicht nach deinem Shampoo dann eher, wenn du da mit dem Kopf draufliegst auf deinem Kissen?
Wie gesagt, das rieche ich ja auch, das ist ja was anderes, den Geruch kenne ich ja auch. Mein Kissen riecht jedenfalls nach etwas, ich würde gerne wissen, was es ist. Ich glaube, das ist eine anders gerechnete Version von deinem Körpergeruch. Aber was mit der Bettdecke? Riecht die anders? Ich glaube, die riecht prima nach Sperma, aber das ist ja eine andere Geschichte. Hast du farbige Bettwäsche oder schön weiss? Sehr einfarbig, teilweise zweifarbig mit Mustern. Welche Musse? Wie von einem Künstler Mondrian, so ein bisschen viele Quadrate und Formen, aber die meisten sind einfarbig, würde ich sagen. Wunderbar. Ich bin kein Bettdecken-Konneser. Wollen wir Bettwäsche auf den Markt schmeißen? Schöne Podcasts für Bettwäsche, aber wo nur unser Logo ganz klein drauf ist und dann einfach eine richtig gute... Ganz gross dein Gesicht, finde ich. Wirklich so, einfach ganz oben auch so, dass wenn man schläft und auch auf dem Kopfkissen ist dein Gesicht. Ganz, ja. Auf dem Kopfkissen ist so dein Gesicht, wie du so schläfst und daneben ist noch Platz, damit man sich da daneben hinlegen kann, so als würde man neben dir schläft. Wenn man aufwacht, dann sieht man so meine grossen Augen, die dich anstarren. Ich habe jetzt auch einen Neffen und der ist also kein Feedback, aber Kinder sind schon so dumm einfach, also wirklich so Kleinkinder, weil der hat dann auch so einen Wagen oder halt irgendwie so eine Schale, so ein Liegending da und da ist auf der einen Seite sind Tiere und auf der anderen Seite nicht. Und manchmal, wenn er so seitlich liegt und den Kopf neigt, dann sieht er die Tiere und dann kriegt er Angst vor den Tieren und dann fängt er an zu schreien, weil er Angst hat vor den Tieren. Und mein Bruder kommt dann und dreht einfach seinen Kopf auf die andere Seite, wo keine Tiere sind. Und irgendwann so... Ja. Und dann so... Er dreht die so um und dann beruhigt er sich. Die Tiere sind noch da, aber er kann sie gerade nicht sehen. Nein, was ich nicht sehe, ist kein Problem. Ja, schon klar, aber es ist einfach so bescheuert einfach.
Alright, wir, meine lieben Herren und Damen, sprechen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Ich freue mich darauf, wir haben viel zu besprechen.
Ich erzähle uns bei Reut, für uns geht es mit unserem Urlaub, wir sind ganz gespannt.
Es wird eine aufregende Woche.
Ich wünsche euch eine ganz tolle Woche und wir heben wieder.
Haut rein, macht's gut und tschüss.